yeah hello welcome to this video I'm a
little bit pissed off because to be
honest probably honest because of the
game before that yeah it felt very very
fishy it didn't upload that I was just
too disconcerted by the way that game
went I mean not not like chess wise but
I really felt that something fishy was
going on so no upload for that loss man
so mr. kulit 2015 he has to suffer now
after that yeah it for was kind of sulu
aggressive nonsense to be honest I came
the booth doesn't really fit into this
position at all
okay let's cover the g5 night it weakens
lots of squares so I'm not happy with it
yeah I will just play quickly and then
and play some aggressive moves the usual
style that I usually that are often lose
against people playing random moves
quickly I'm just I'm just doing the same
now with white okay
I did that already looks rather
dangerous okay I'm I want to keep that
bishop
you
the autumn are going to do like 95 97
something like that don't think just
play okay cannot sacrifice yet but it is
rather close and yeah okay so my idea
was that you cannot already take it but
how do i get rid of the Queen down maybe
like goopy 1 p-5
ok five Queen D for check or what is the
idea you can also know just go here
right I'll take on d3 but after I can go
here intending group g3 I can also go
here
check check so like I surviving this
really Rock g5 is a big threat but ever
you have to check mate now everything
else is not enough he's really totally
winning on the queenside yes this move
this move irritated me I have to admit
that didn't quite see how to win him
okay pragmatic choice I ruchi five is
still a pretty massive threat
I just had a talk he busted on the
Creekside I really have to deliver mate
now everything else is it's not enough
maybe you can play I night itself can
you form okay
now that should work right that should
work then it's a good defense
don't see how to get more pieces into
that tick check
yeah I don't have much much time here
you know I to do to get especially i
cannot i cannot activate my queen this
is the biggest issue here I'm ready
like a surprise that you did that but it
probably wins I mean I'm not saying it
doesn't but I felt he had simpler things
now yeah okay i can check here it
doesn't help time morning so quincy one
not very attractive but i know is going
94 right damn well i knew that this
attack wasn't entirely correct but still
it's still yo that you can get somewhere
I could have won a lot easier and
quicker but wow
check Wow check check it's the maid I
don't see a medium okay let's take the
Rope him didn't see I made wow black
resides that was one of the most lost
positions that i had in recent times i
think actually up to here it was it was
kind of a maniac play but it wasn't
terribly bad or anything this must be
some kind of kind of dangerous attack i
mean at least this is some of this
playable but maybe maybe this is
starting to put things to the extreme
yeah check check yeah this is this is a
like going on in there all in and hoping
check it objectively shouldn't work this
is a good move yeah now black black is
winning Luke g8 is also strong check and
here I'm lost I really just lost not BTW
five wins but i think what he did wasn't
the best but probably still very
comfortably winning yeah this is already
a big mistake 95 is winning quite
comfortably now where am i going with
the bishop not know where I guess neji 6
I could have played here right this is
chris is cool this is actually a row
this is such a big threat group takes
she ate that he has to go
then we repeat so g6 b5 and now I'm
winning I'm just winning now crazy yeah
this is a chance may dang it jackin it
extremely easy yeah just immensely lucky
but did it show sometimes those kind of
wacky attacks and they are not easy to
defend against impractical plane so yeah
this is how it works sometimes thanks
for watching